this is very concerning for adam uh in
regards to declassified government
secrets shocking declassified government
secrets trained cat soldiers okay
documents declassified in 1983 revealed
that the u.s government tested the idea
of training cats to be spies
implanting
recording equipment in their bodies and
letting them loose near the kremlin or
soviet embassy is this a true story it's
a true
story that's my people it's a true
people it's a true story cat spies out
there i'm here to tell you
that it was called acoustic kitty and uh
it was an operation and uh you know
where people can learn a lot about this
is on black files declassified which
appears every wednesday night there you
go
you're not selfish at all am i doing
this right exactly yeah um
discovery channel channel science
channel science challenge discovery plus
yeah and uh so
the idea was um
was that uh yeah the idea was that look
again uh if you're trying to collect
intelligence you're going to try to be
creative the one thing that one of the
things that the agency does well they've
got a science and technology directorate
right that's one of the
divisions in within the organization and
that's where incredible engineers work
and they've developed everything from
the u2 you know to the blackbird to
satellite you know technology uh
battery capability um and so
they do some amazing work down there and
one of the ideas was look if you know if
you're trying to collect on some target
in some you know country and
um maybe what you want to do is figure
out a way to get close to that target in
an unassuming way how about we implant
um a receiver
into a cat
i mean i know that sounds crazy but the
these guys are just throwing ideas out
there they built a a
years ago they have decades ago they
built a thing called an except
insecticopter which was just a little
dragonfly that could hover and and you
know outside a window of say the soviet
embassy and uh collect uh intel
um
it's it's incredible anyway the acoustic
kitty didn't work uh they also tried why
didn't it work um yeah cats are as it
turns out are not that trainable
oh i know mike yeah yeah there you go so
it's basically desertion right yeah yeah
so they as it turns out you know the cat
base i i don't know i i don't have uh
all the insight but i think it spent
most of its time licking its own ass and
um those are more dogs yeah yeah well
let me ask you which created
interference and static on the little
you know the static phil the term for um
phil what is it uh like international
arms dealers we've seen the movie war
dogs right yeah yes and then in the
movies like he's a dog of war right yeah
how this cat idea
how much thought goes into it or
realistically how like how often does
just someone just hide [ __ ] smoking weed
he's like man forget about war dog war
cats man that's where it's at well no
they you think it is crazy right because
some of the [ __ ] that they came up with
was it was just remarkable um as an
example they built a fish a remote fish
right because they were trying to figure
out what was going on at a facility
overseas somewhere and it had an estuary
right and so what they want to do is
collect water samples so there's no way
in hell they were going to be able to
accomplish this so anyway they built
this fish they have a copy or one of
them in the uh museum there at
headquarters it's incredible it's a fake
fish looks just like a damn fish and
this thing would they set it off and it
would swim up the you know estuary and
collect water samples and could you know
gather some other data and then come
back i mean so yeah they're throwing
ideas on the table but sometimes you
know it makes sense they again the
acoustic kitty didn't work they tried it
on a pigeon right and you know the the
gear was too heavy for the pigeon to
make it all the way
to the target so but you never you know
and and you know some of the ones that
really work they don't they don't talk
but these are the kind of wacky ideas or
they're like let's put a budget together
let's put 20 million dollars into this
isn't the right word for a dolphin
yeah dolphins are yeah look they they
that's very famous right
yeah and and look animals you know the
ones that could be trained you know
could you know could be used in this
this sense what they then went to what
this developed into was robotics right
and and uh and so the use of of uh you
know the insectothopter was a very
important development because while it
didn't necessarily work that well
because it wasn't as controllable as
they wanted it to be
it allowed them to
develop technology that could then be
used in other ways and so
you know anyway i'm banging on about to
all i can think about right now yeah all
i can think about right now is in the
austin powers movie where he's like
sharks with lasers exactly
we're gonna have sharks and put lasers
on them those laser beams scat
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]